Our fifth architectural style is implicit invocation.
And here let's first examine the question of reliability.
Well, if you're approached to event delivery,
in an implicit invocation style it's centralized you are more easily able to
deal with unexpected events, thereby improving reliability.
On the other hand, because interactions are implicit, overall system
understandability is reduced, potentially compromising reliability.
Or the other four system qualities, performance, might be
compromised because of the extra communication due to the bookkeeping and
indirection can lead to context swapping problems.
Maintainability, there may be increased reuse due to the independents of
the components.
On the other hand, as far as safety is concerned,
increased interaction complexity may make it harder to ensure safety.
And with to respect security as we saw with object orientated,
object orientation, the fragmentation of an implicit location architectural
style can cause problems, but encapsulation can help to mitigate them.